you're pretty quiet now Mike am i that's
probably for the best Wyatt last week
I had no se marchó I sin just like Loki
say much listen say much know your your
your volume is great your opinions were
quite useless well I hadn't played the
game which the internet which which the
comments didn't like very much which
switch I got what it great I love seeing
our thread blow up when all of a sudden
you hit just a magical moment in the
game and and all you had to do is put in
two words and we knew exactly where you
were Ilana high coffee buddy hello put
yourself
Austin yeah we have Austin Wintory
I always forget the audit t next video
game at Detroit Baker and video game
director who was also a because we don't
have it is it goes anyway watch the
video right now I think the conversation
might have been sparked in part because
there's a former Sony executive who said
video games are too long this is the
thing that I feel like comes up all the
time depending on your doing in life I
feel like parents especially I like why
they make the video game too long but
this was specifically Shawn Layden so
it's not like it you know wasn't someone
who said he would welcome their return
of the 12 to 15 hour game I would finish
small games first of all just like a
well edited piece of literature or a
movie I've been looking at the
discipline around that the containment
around that it could get us tied a more
compelling content it would be something
I'd like to see our return to and I've
actually felt for a while that the
impact of services like game pause is
probably going to be that we do see some
shorter games come to those services
because it's kind of more of a risk to
come out and use this week
micros no more robots said that
descenders which is a game I found on
game policin really loves sold three
times as well after they put it on game
pause meaning it's just that exposure a
lot more people know that game exists
but that is in theory a short game that
works very well for the game pause
formula I also played Abzu on game pause
and then bought it when it came off but
it does seem like we've got we go
similar boosts sorry we've got similar
boosts on Thomas was alone I think cuz I
have here in-game pass yeah I think
we've I don't know if we ever said that
publicly but yeah I think we've we've
seen it when you give away something for
free turns out people talk about it it's
how rocket League took off and that
became huge Bioshock did the majority of
its sale of sales when it went on as a
Steam sale and it actually made more
money even though they like way lower
the price and and just anything that Ken
Levine taught me was that he was like
there's a barrier to where you once you
go below this rate this this number any
further discount is negligible so he was
like we put it to this and the majority
it went from like I don't know 4 million
5 million copies that it did to like
something like rocketing over like seven
or eight it was it wasn't specifically
infinite specifically interested steam
sales like a fall so it wasn't like July
or whatever my pals over at supergiant
said that when Bastion first came out it
was not a hit out of the gate at all and
they were basically like oh we might be
screwed and funny enough the the high
engagement rate on the soundtrack album
especially through band camp Darin corbs
yeah kick-ass soundtrack that that
actually that actually was some useful
quick quick access revenue for the
company because you know you have you
have basically instant access to revenue
through band camp sales and they were
seeing a high percentage of people play
the game who would then get the album
but then I think he said it came out in
like March or something of that year
but it was like the Halloween steam
Sailor summer of Xbox I thought it was
on the it was definitely on the Xbox
that's how I got it it may evoke aid
that's what yeah whatever it was it was
I think the fall Steam sale or something
that triggered it to just absolutely
explode and then you know and it's still
it's still I mean as big of a hit as
transistor was which i think was an even
bigger hit I think like day by day
bastion is still like doing respectable
numbers and it was that initial like
critical mass of people that the sale
got is crazy I had no idea it's one of
those that you remember it Yuri Yuri
canonize that as likes Bastion once it
always a hit yeah exactly
no made more money sorry it also made
less money in its first six months on
sale than the week after that so it's
like yeah Wow sales and a couple of
youtubers yeah it's it's it's like
Austin says after the fact we always go
well obviously Thomas was alone right
out the gate everyone loved it I thought
it was I thought it was like this with
my job I didn't quit my job until yeah
until about seven months after Thomas
was when I came out I released Thomas
was alone and I went back to work and
basically like was like well I guess you
know I'll try and make another indie
game in a few years or something and it
was it took like six months for it so
it's it's exhausting says we
recontextualize things to with with um
with hindsight - oh there's obviously
there's always going to be hmm I feel
like um we could have a whole episode
about that but yeah from this
conversation about game Pawson and sales
is like my my thought process is I feel
like the way that Xbox at least and that
means that probably other people are
doing it and just not being it's obvious
about it are approaching the next
generation is very much focused on that
subscription service rather than being
focused on hardware or exclusives not
that they don't have exclusives too but
that makes me think that yes this is
going to change the landscape and that
maybe people will start making shorter
games to put on game pass because I feel
like it is sort of a bit more of a
financial risk to put something on there
knowing that is really their Drive
because obviously the
on PC too and it's such a good service
if you don't have game passes it's it's
very very good it's absolutely worth it
but Mike you're a person that I did want
to talk to about this what's the longest
game that you've made haha my pin job
Mike actually I think knowing that
clocks in about six hours
so our stuff is really short yeah so
when you approach how long the games
you're making are is that a number that
you have from the start literally how do
you decide or how does that come about
the length of a video again I think for
us it's usually like an arbitrary thing
we just we pick a number and then run
towards that and then adjust as we go on
so there's a hundred levels of Thomas
was alone the only reason is it's a nice
round number and then as we did it that
kind of made sense with with John wick I
think very early on Austin correct me if
I'm wrong but I feel like we worked out
like there are going to be it's seven
locations in John wick like there's many
seven locations but then where is a lot
back and forth on like how big do we how
long do we spend in each location how
big is a level for me though yeah our
stuff our games as well varying price a
lot so we've done like five dollar games
ten dollar games twenty dollar games and
I think that impacts it for sure like
there's definitely a correlation like
what you can get away with in a five
dollar game versus what you can do in
twenty dollars and I assume I'll see if
we ever did do like a $60 game those
expectations would shoot up again you
know are you saying specifically for
time like like you I can I can get away
with I know by now I've made enough
games to know that each hour per game I
can quantify dollar-wise month wise
recently yeah yeah historically it feels
like there's been like a dollar value
people want to spend for an hour of an
indie game that's for you though like to
me yeah no that's yeah oh oh to make it
a return no so them them so what would
you mean do you mean like in terms of
like the cost per hour of me yeah like I
can look at a film and say on average 4
/ 5 minutes of film there's about 8
hours of filming right on a movie so if
you haven't go per hour of gameplay I'm
looking at 3 months of dev with 12
people at an average burn rate of
$30,000 a month or where are you able to
there's some there's some
it's weird in the its there's a weird
kind of there's two questions there
because to use your movie analogy you're
both making the movie but you're also
making the VCR that's never heard of
this Jurassic like so - using examples
like a triple-a game
right you've got to make all of the
systems and all of the structure of a
triple-a game and all of the AI of the
combat mechanics everything that is how
you play that game right it's job one
and then job two is all the content and
what's weird is because of the way games
are made frankly and so that they get
shipped in anything approaching like a
reasonable amount of time you tend to do
those two things simultaneously which is
the worst way of doing it but like often
you've got no choice you always gonna
take 15 years to make a video game so
what you have this weird situation where
you're kind of those things are running
in parallel and that's one of the
reasons there's been a member when this
when this when this this games are too
long the kind of conversation came up in
my feed there are lots of developers
saying it doesn't take half as long to
make a game that's half as long to play
right it takes the same amount of time
because you have to make if it's got the
mechanical depth like in to use last of
us because we have become the unofficial
last of us podcast like I remember
reading about the first game and Troy
you can tell me if this is true the AI
for the for the basically for any moment
we're in a I was NBC was running
alongside you and was cooperating with
you in the space that was only finalized
like months before ship yep it was so
there was one hundred percent broken it
was 100 percent broken and having worked
on games with similar mechanics that
have come in that hot as well like it's
that means by definition to make all of
those mechanics you couldn't have made
last of us faster probably there are
without changing efficiencies in
production different management pros
like there there's ways you can change
how games are made but it's not a simple
matter of if you make the game half the
length it takes off as long to make
interesting the team that was making
their content for last of us were making
that over here and there's there's still
influence because I mean I was I
remember working on a game called um
dead to rights
years and years ago and that had a level
where the basically I came you always
you're you're a badass cop with a with a
dog who runs alongside you admissions we
had one level where you were accompanied
by human NPC and they had similar
similar our last of us does it they're
kind of providing support and trying not
to look stupid which is the main job of
any companion NPC in video game right
and I remember that was coming in
similarly hot and that mentor those of
us who are working I was working briefly
but other people were more responsible
on the levels where that character was
present we were cheating all over the
place - trying to fake anything we could
that made it not look bad and then when
the when the AI guys kind of figured it
out towards the end and everything tide
came in then there was a mad scramble to
like undo all of our all of our tweaking
to make it work just so that we could
get something good that so there is it's
it's symbiotic but it's not one-to-one
though there is no as you say there's no
like this is the manpower needed to make
an hour of game content because remember
there's emphasized inside of us and you
said how long that's a two and a half
hour game maybe did you work on inside
no no no no we were just talking about
it a lot and and how long for them to
make that I think it was like seven
years or something to make that game no
way although to crow to quote andreia
casino because I think he's probably
right about this his his assessment of
that was I think they had a functional
gray box within six months and then six
and a half years of absolutely perfect
polish because it's a game that has no
flaws I don't have and sometimes as well
you have to make three bad games to have
the good game at the end of it like
there's a lot of like wasted time where
you'll go not with that game but with
definitely again with other games I mean
those within the really bad versions of
that game before you actually arrive at
the one where it's at all this clicks
like they're like the the early demos of
almost every game we've made you
wouldn't recognize them compared to what
the final game was that's my definition
wasted work but you have to sometimes
you have to go down those paths to find
out what not to do so you can make a
good thing yeah I mean every every
project I've worked on there's been
glimpses of that I remember on journey
there was even a brief flirtation of it
being a four-player thing on combat as
well right like rifles yes exactly it
was very competitive in the leaderboards
no but I remember
No on when I got hired on Assassin's
Creed syndicate I remember they were
about they hadn't announced the release
date yet but they were about a year from
the release a little less than that and
I remember I pulled up all the they were
showing me just giving me a tour through
everything that is like on the day that
literally my first meeting they're
showing me okay here's what we've got so
far you know here a bunch of
work-in-progress cinematics and all that
and I was blown away by how rough a lot
of things were still like they were very
placeholder and and they were also using
the like like typed to speech sort of
placeholder robot voices everybody over
here yeah exactly for all the dialogues
and I remember saying you know I I said
how long have you guys been been working
on this so far because you know Ubisoft
will have like these different parallel
productions of you know the the the the
Montreal team will be working on one AC
and then the the Quebec City team will
be working on a different AC so that
they're kind of staggered and I said you
know because I think I think unity had
only come out the year before and I saw
I was like when did you start this game
and they said oh you know I can't
remember now but well let's say two and
a half three years ago and I was like
everything is so rough and I was like
what have you been doing all this to
like forgive my ignorance but what the
hell have you been doing and they were
like basically building this and then
it's like the fly through a [ __ ]
fully fleshed out Victorian London where
it's just we need a few years to just
build the tech to support running around
like getting on a horse in the middle of
a city well there's six months of work
like it's just insane all those systems
because then it was like okay yeah Paul
Amos and Victoria Atkin let's flood them
in at the last second now and populate
their work throughout the game and get
the music in at the last second other
because it just takes so I say last
second but that last year is where all
the content really came to life because
years prior just to because the scope of
it is mind-bogglingly huge shadow moss
in the same way homie yeah you are
crackling again but I was gonna ask you
Alston in terms of like your involvement
as a composer syndicate is obviously a
way longer game than journey did they
take dramatically different amount
time to make apologies for the crackling
I uh well it's I think that's a really
hard apples to apples comparison I'm
sure Michael backed me up on this from a
from a specifically kind of a tech and
Dev standpoint but I mean journey much
like Mike's games you know that's they
made their own engine that's it that's
okay I mean that's not not to do that
but I'm saying I know I know I'm just
saying I'm not real poder as there's the
YouTube yeah that that's one where they
are they are starting everything from
scratch AC they have simply your
involvement though when it comes to
composing it did I had way more time on
journey than on syndicate like three
times more I was on journey the entirety
of development which was three years I
literally we joke around that on journey
the first concept art was my theme
because Jenova Chen sat me down and said
the flower had shipped like a week
before so journey has not officially
greenlit and he said yeah but they had a
three game contract with Sony so it was
presumed to be green that but you still
have to go through the motions and
present it to Sony and say here's what
we want to make and they have to
officially give you the thumbs up and so
he said you know here's kind of what I
have in mind for the game and there's a
whole story that I enjoy telling but
I'll skip it for now but the long and
short of it was that they gave me the
the rundown of what the aspiration for
the game would be and said can you go
kind of write some music cuz Genoa's
whole thing and I think it's kind of
just a general that game company idea
was we like to use music as a kind of
North Star for the team more than any
other particular element like where
where if if we all agree how this music
makes us feel then that can help
everybody know that they're on the right
path like if you if your artwork or your
you know design or your you know
whatever shaders if everything feel if
it doesn't if anything kind of deviates
from the agreed-upon emotion of this
music then you can know that you may be
drifting since emotions are kind of all
that they care about it's reductive to
say but it is a such a crucial
thing Jenova works backwards from the
way a lot of developers work just as a
minor tangent because he'll very often a
developer will think of a really cool
mechanic or a great narrative conceit or
something and say how do I turn that
into a game and Genova will think of an
emotion and say what mechanics would
make me feel that way and he has no
aspirin
there's no idea ahead of time of oh it's
gonna be this kind of game that kind of
game it's just I want to feel this and
wherever I can find a thing that makes
me feel that way that's the game I'm
gonna make like in the case of journey
it was I want to feel alone and then I
want to feel connected with somebody in
a way that has zero antagonism and zero
rivalry and any of the kind of online
competitive multiplayer sort of standard
relationships he's like I want to I want
to find a way to feel like I care I even
love a total stranger and so every
decision and journey was how do we make
a thing that feels that way and so we
had worked together on our first game
flow a few years earlier and so he just
approached and said are you interested
in writing a theme and I wrote a theme
in Matt Nava had some concept art you
know within a day or two and we were off
and running and it was only three years
later that it shipped whereas on
syndicate yeah it was like here's a
mostly finished game but with a lot of
placeholder content and then just
because there was also three tie a
thirty as much time but three times more
music in syndicate than journey more
than that so yeah there but there's so
many differences you know it's really uh
also journey as Mike said journey was a
lot of like experimenting and failing a
lot of let's try to do this okay six
months down that road it's not working
let's back all the way back to the
starting gate and try again whereas
syndicate it was like the sixth
Assassin's Creed game there were a lot
of knowns and there were a lot of things
we know work and things were trying to
improve upon and iterate on from overall
as a franchise from unity or Black Flag
specifically etc etc so it's it's a
really tough comparison you have a lot
of advantage going into a game like it's
syndicate for sure with journey did you
know the length going in like how do you
know how they decided the length of that
game because that journey is especially
short yeah that was it was a big kind of
controversy
I was overwhelmingly positively received
but it the length of it seems to be the
common thread amongst the dissenters I
mean there's of course also the folks
that are like you know there's no you
don't do anything so to hell with it I
walking simulator began as a hard
pejorative you know and and and so it
there are people that just it's not for
them in terms of the actual gameplay but
for a lot especially because the price
point became this discussion of like
well this is really more of a fifteen to
twenty dollar game even though you knows
the budget was way over what it had
originally specked out to be in three is
yeah it's three years instead of like a
year and change and and so there were
multiple extensions and the team
expanded and and so there were a lot of
sort of discussions most of which I of
course I wasn't in the room for but I
kind of and caught wind of second hand
and that that you know they were like
well we can't over price this game for
what it is you know it was supposed to
be a PlayStation Network exclusive all
these kinds of like it was supposed to
you know because back in those days you
know there was still the novelty of the
downloadable as as a thing like most
games were still kind of primarily box
titles that was still that we're still
that transition point so yeah I was it
was um it was there was just a lot of
kind of head scratching and anxiety
about what to charge for it and the
length was I think a big thing of you
know are people gonna expect a longer
game at a higher price as opposed to a
better game you know because the the
people the people if you look through
comments especially in the early days on
YouTube of Let's Plays or someone will
go I can't believe somebody wasted $15
on a game that's an hour long or 90
minutes and most 45 minutes if you are
brisk you know how can you waste your
money and then there would inevitably be
a piling on of people saying so somehow
grinding for gear for an extra three
hours makes your money better spent like
every moment of this game had meaning
and purpose there was no fat to trim and
isn't that like wouldn't you rather
spend something that's that meaningful
and I'm certainly in that camp although
journey was a way to help me reveal that
because I was a kind of traditional
gamer I think growing up you know it's
all about
it's all about the shooty shooty and
stuff as I say that I mean like I was
like grim fandago is like your favorite
game ever made so I'm totally
caricaturing myself yeah I'm doing not
much
although beautiful flowers that do
results when you when you do a little
bit of the shooty shooty but so yeah
oh it's great anyway I'm being overly
long-winded here but yeah I I think that
game for me really brought to the fore
the notion of how do we value dollars as
a time factor because I I certainly
perhaps brainwashed by the very biasing
experience of working on that game and
just how special and and career
trajectory altering it was of a lot of
love for it and it really it really buys
me in favor of the idea that dollars are
spent in earnestness like if inside was
half that long but that equally as
polished as it is I would pay the same
price because it's like quality for me
value is so much more valuable no I
don't pay $60 for any of that games
going forward because I know what that
games all having played their last three
so I would absolutely continue to do
that very secure well yeah I think
that's a very anomalous opinion too
because I think that the continuing
argument that I've heard and I even put
something up on Twitter about this - or
people are saying we we want to know
what we're getting because people don't
have just like people are aren't as
benefits or as privileged as we are to
be able to be given download codes or be
given copies of the game it's like oh
yeah for multiple games you know I buy
funny a game still but I can afford to
do that
and so do i exactly I'm the same way so
it's it's but there's a lot people's
like I can probably buy four or I don't
you know my kind of depend upon my
parents or grandparents or whatever to
be able to give me that one gift for my
birthday or for Christmas and this is
what I'm gonna get so I have to I have
to be very very prudent about which
title I get so I understand it was like
if you is like I'm gonna I'm gonna turn
in my card for this three hour game
you're like yeah
you know there's there's this thing that
I want to be I want a 60 hour experience
or I want a just a continual thing that
is going to be more event based like a
fortnight situation to where it's just
this perpetual giving kind of thing I I
just don't understand this blanket
statement of they're too long or they're
too short when it is that's a subjective
thing it's salt in the sauce it's like
what do you mean and let the story look
like but the dev tell their story let
the devic their game if you want to
think it was too long great but that
doesn't mean that hey we need to change
the way the games are made because these
are too long to shoes where I think it's
especially interesting I absolutely
think you're writing that this should be
a game by game basis the pot where it
gets really interesting is where the dev
has decided a length and then a
publisher has told them we need four
more hours in this and that's where you
feel games are too long I put everything
that happened background because I
believed that that was an instance of
that way alien isolation is very very
very very good and then there's another
eight hours on top of what you think the
climax is over and over and over again
that I know some people didn't have a
problem with but for me it was like why
do you keep giving me climaxes and keep
giving me things that are written like
endings and then there's more game it
just like became draining and became a
thing that I was like let this be over
and I think that there are cases where
that happens where it does feel like a
publisher mandated we need more hours in
this thing I don't think I agree about
alien isolation I'm just saying but the
publisher is actually the one that's
that's putting that on because to me the
publisher would be going scope scope
scope scope scope what's the cheapest
that you can get this game done and
knowing that you're gonna add eight
hours of content is I think it's I think
it's the other way around saying for
sure like it's if people definitely want
to have that good number that I really
liked that was too short and then just
kind of didn't sell because people like
what do you mean it's something it's a
six hour game with no money or anything
else is like yikes I mean there's a lot
of there's a lot of behind the scene
there shall that happen that that's
probably to remain behind you know
confident have to speak to it yeah but I
I know that that was a challenging
relationship between ready dawn and and
and Sony but as someone as someone who
actually did work on that game but the
the there's a project I'm actually I'm
working on right now that I also can't
speak about but this exact conversation
has has come up where they're it's it's
not that they want to find ways to make
it cheaper and reduce scope like you
were saying a second ago Troy it's that
they're saying we've already spent this
much and therefore you know to recoup on
our investment we think we want to
target this price point and if we're
coming in noticeably below the kind of
average runtime of games of this price
point we're not gonna see a return on
our investment so it has to be longer
just because the math is starting to not
work and I sympathize with that that's
time actually happy I've had it even of
the like pitching stage where like
there's I'm thinking of one one specific
game in one specific publisher where we
basically went in with you know a
concise in my opinion good game it's a
bits of it have ended up in our other
games I don't know if we'll ever
actually make that game but it's found
its way into lots of other stuff but it
was a good indie game four or five hours
kind of where we normally sit with our
games and there was a price point
attached to it and that publisher said
will only work with you if we make this
five times the budget and four times the
length and and and that in in that room
in that moment when someone across from
you is offering you more money than
you've ever imagined having and saying
please you know basically make a
completely different scale of game
that's I can see totally why CEOs that
do that we we chose not to because we
had other opportunities and we go in
different directions but like those
moments exist and there is it is is a
it's a it's a bullet point it's a an
expectation I think what's interesting
is I feel like the conversation is
maturing to a point
we're I'm fascinated by this idea of
editors because if something games have
never done we never know we've never
deleted lots of stuff from games that
doesn't that doesn't happen because you
spend so much let me try let me clarify
that just a fix that facial expression
of yours but a lot of little bit a lot
of Mike catalyzed Troy expressions we
don't we we remove stuff because it's
buggy we remove stuff because it's not
fun we remove stuff because it doesn't
fit what we don't tend to do is
literally kind of edit stuff out for
narrative or pacing it's not something I
I don't think is done we don't take
things to a point where they're built
and finished the the reason why I make
that face and not to don't want to pull
focus but that the reason why there's a
there's a studio that I worked on that
there was a very very big set piece and
they're like there's the deal we can
either throw all the resources that we
have on making sure that this thing is
as good is and up to par with the rest
of the game or the rest of the game will
suffer because the rest of the game has
to be made and they cut it and this is a
but that's a that's a script I made it
Dan made it it was a design it was it
impacted gameplay narrative design
everything there was you're saying is
that there was more work to do to get it
finished
that was the briefs make us it was they
couldn't finish it to a polish level my
definition they were the previous oh
you're saying everything is finished
we've shot everything essentially right
we've put everything in or like bad
gonna take this up like that's something
that's really like I think most
developers would go no screw you we
spend a lot of money on that a lot of
time and right bobs level we all a mess
it but there are definitely games where
as a player I could stand to lose a few
hours of that game and my overall
experience of that game would probably
be better because those things are rude
the other thing I think is really
interesting and where I'm excited by
some of the work that different Studios
are doing is making this a player choice
I I've been saying it for a while I know
this is blasphemy I would love to be
able to play the 10-hour version of
Witcher 3 I would just just show me the
best bits of that game edit the hell out
of it you're saying Witcher 3 shouldn't
be
sixty hours for everyone who wants it to
be but I have not said I've not I'm not
gonna finish
I've played like the first location in
that game and then stopped because I was
like that's taken me six hours seven
hours I don't have this five other games
I need to play I have a you know job and
and commitments and stuff to do I would
love that I love and something that yeah
lots of games are getting very good
accessibility we talked about on the
last episode but I don't thing I wonder
is if we're gonna start seeing kind of
time and editing being and scale being
option I would spend the same amount
money for which for as you would but I
would play the mode which just got me to
the good stuff quick you know is that is
that a trend because I've never actually
I think players would actually to be a
really interesting reaction I was signed
up for that I'm with you I version of
the game and you play a criterion
collection menu like I want the five
hour experience I want the 10 hour
experience I like the idea of that even
though historically players have hated
this because if they devalue the work I
put into it but what's fascinating about
the accessibility discussion and what I
think is shifted I'm gonna let you talk
a second try promise I think what's
shifting is I think players are gaining
the kind of understanding and maturity
to not worry like there are like in most
of us to there's loads of accessibility
features that make the game
quote-unquote easier you know if you're
someone who doesn't need those
accessibility features you can make the
game as easy as you want it to be so
basically doesn't quite play itself but
you can simplify everything you don't
have to aim the gun in Last of Us to you
can just switch on the thing of auto
aims and you don't have to have to worry
about aiming your left arm see that's
brilliant
that opens the game up to a broader
audience it's brilliant it's fun
two three years ago players would have
been on the forums complaining that that
devalued their experience and they were
you know people you know get good people
should be able to play the game like
this but players aren't really talking
about that or I'm not seeing much of
that I wonder if we're heading towards a
point where players are gonna accept
like no you know Mike and Austin want to
play which are for they don't want to
put in the time I'm going to put in let
them have their version that doesn't
devalue my version I get to have the
real proper experience but they get the
fun tourist version more contouring
right no no not at all more people I
think you're dead-on more people are
experiencing games by not playing them
than they are playing them so any
interaction with the game is is a
tremendous you know uptick in in
engagement I just think that I I
remember specifically if you've ever
seen the kid stays in the picture or
read the book the the biography
autobiography really of Bob Evans big
Hollywood producer that produced you
know movies like The Godfather Chinatown
it's incredible he tells the story where
he goes Francis Coppola comes in and
you've told this story on this show how
I yeah well tell it again because we
love it
I'm gonna I'm gonna be like I'm gonna be
like River at the end of serenity show
gets new this is every week after after
you know an hour and a half the the
lights come back up and the real runs
out and Bob Evans looks as Francis and
he goes you shot an epic and you turn in
a trailer give me the rest of my [ __ ]
movie and I think that if you gave this
especially I imagine the disparity
between the reviews that people would
given the experience of people that was
like that game was [ __ ] was like well
did you get to the aliens you're like
what yeah I understand like narratively
that is a minefield especially when it
comes it's a terrible idea like to be
clear so be clear like I don't think
anyone should there so there's I but but
it's one of those things and this is or
this is I think I've said this on the
show as well we're doing all our heads
in and game developments that was
everything every mandalorian how
everything is stupid and impossible
right up until you see it appear in
three games in one year like and there's
you know it's the kind of thing where
like I'm talking about it and I kind of
want to try putting in my next game
because I think it's a it could be it
could fail miserably but imagine if it
worked like I mean we we had it in sub
service owned some service circular it's
like it
xbase game and we have like scrolling
text and we have one feature in that
game which is the text scrolls kind of
an auto speed and the first person you
talk to you've had a chat with them for
ten minutes they say to you sorry am I
talking too fast and you get to choose
kind of to like you can recalibrate
based right as speed at which speech
happens in the game that feature took
like an afternoon and so many players
just love that and say oh it so cool
that you can kind of adjust how the how
the game and you can basically turn you
know to our game into a two and a half
hour game by slowing down or an hour
game by speaking it up and just stuff
like that just I think players really
respond well to I think it'd be a fun
thing to experiment with and I'm
definitely talking myself into trying
this no I think there's a there's a kind
of there's a kind of interesting
spin-off discussion that that leads to
that your Godfather comparison also kind
of taps into troy of the idea of the
thing that fundamentally separates games
from all other media is the invitation
of the player to to be an active
participant and to not just sit in a
chair and say let me let me tell you a
story let me take you on an adventure
etc etc so it to me the assertion of the
like the authorship of Coppola and and
and everybody else involved in the
Godfather is sort of expected in the
medium of film because it's like this is
not a two-way relationship this is I
mean on some levels it is but it is
essentially a passive consumption of
like I'm gonna sit in my chair and watch
this film right and and this I remember
the first time this ever came up was
actually on my very first game flow with
Kelly Santiago where we got into a
debate of should it be allowed for the
player to kind of like Spotify didn't
exist then but to kind of
anachronistically mess up my story it on
a game like flow where the music and
sound designer are half the game
experience because it's just so kind of
Zen and meditative by nature uh should
the player be able to kind of like
toggle a thing in the menu that just
integrates some Spotify playlist into it
of their of their choosing
I think and I said
and I said to her that's kind of where
I'm at now but I said at the time I was
like what no we are we are providing an
authored experience and this is kind of
like what you were saying last week
about the Last of Us like I don't care
if you ultimately don't like it insofar
as I care that I have fairly represented
the story I want to tell her the
experience I want to create and her
response was where the experience we're
trying to create though is one in which
the players have agency and why not just
extend that agency even into some
foundational elements of the gameplay
itself and it really it's like tormented
me for 15 years now because I'm like
[ __ ] it's true like maybe my my entire
contribution to a game could
theoretically be superfluous if a player
said look I John wick head [ __ ]
awesome but I would rather play Tyler
Bates music while I mean lovely like the
second all of game developers about ten
years ago will agree to put like a music
volume separates in the settings by that
at that moment play music became a
player choice laugh and there are lets
players who play them all the time so
for every review at IGN music has to go
completely off which means that when I'm
capturing gameplay there is no sound wah
licensing problems so where we have so
like what I'm reviewing you mean if you
I'm still listening to the audience when
I'm not shine which I generally do it's
because you're like I need to capture
these moments for the it's because of
the YouTube monetization issues you can
get a strike so the Christian contem
essa who was I think lead designer on
red dead not not red did too but Red
Dead Redemption and he was also the lead
writer and lead narrative writer and the
director for shadow of mordor the first
one said something that's really really
stuck with me he said we can make the
mistake of thinking that the player is a
writer and the player is not a writer
the player is an editor we provide the
content and they edit so whenever we go
what do you think player it is actually
an illusion of agency and a perfect
sense that like a telltale game you're
not writing your story you're choosing
of the ones of the bucket of things that
we give to you but ultimately we're
gonna we're gonna make this thing come
down to a tee and it's gonna tell the
story that we want to tell you just
stick if you get to have some agency as
you go along so I think when you say
well we want to extend that that agency
to the player it's like yeah but like
you said you're creating an authored
experience is a difference and we can
make a mistake of turning players into
writers and there's they suck as writers
they're not literally hot daughters we
literally had that debate like last week
where we're at a point with one of our
projects where like we're looking in the
script and there's a moment a big big
moment in the story where where I've
written it in a linear way it's a story
event that occurs and one of the people
who was checking on the script and how
it gave me feedback said could could
that be a player choice that feels like
a moment where a player could choose an
angle and the response was for me was is
the other choice as interesting like
here's the other choice we've got a
choice in this script which is a cool
story moment also a character makes a
choice the player doesn't if we give the
player control over that are they going
to if they choose the other one is that
as interesting and the answer is
definitely no and that was a really
interesting moment which is very sad we
were saying we don't make it a choice
right yeah and I think that's true
that's what's also really interesting in
the conversation around editing games is
you can play games at your choosing the
pace of a game by the pace you run
through it was really interesting to me
playing lost of us one again recently
I slept ill an easy mode because I just
I want to see the story again when i
refresh myself on the on the
stubbornness get every reference and I
play lost was charged one breeze through
it I think I enjoyed it more playing it
through again on the easy mode than I
had playing on like hard mode when it
came out because I myself know I was
playing probably I loved playing that
game with the aesthetics of survivors
and the aesthetics of being a danger
situation but never running out health
kids
I really prefer I got through it like
every time these days to that I play
every first-person shooter on hard
because I like playing a first-person
shooter where I have to like be very
reflexive and I can die immediately but
a lot of action adventures if there's a
boss fight that's annoying me I will
drop it down easy which I never used to
do I used to play
everything on hard and now I like I'm
willing to if the tools are there tailor
it to how much I'm enjoying a particular
thing so if I don't like the boss fight
and it's difficult I'm like I'll drop it
down easy I don't care did you guys do
anything I would have done that if that
if that had been an option I would have
dropped that down because I never
finished that game because the final
boss fight is just [ __ ]
but like go ahead go on then I'm sorry
is gonna say that's editing and and with
loss of us too
I was playing it earlier I'm having some
time off working on so I'm just burning
through Last of Us and finally after not
playing it before I'll spoil a
conversation that's fun um the but like
I was running I was running through a
space earlier and there was you know
there were two buildings I went in one I
done the whole finding all the
collectables I was I was looking at the
other building and there was a story
moment off to the right I knew I know
the game's well enough to know if I run
right under they hid the story moment I
looked at the building I was like I
actually don't care what's in that
building I just want to get to the cool
story thing I'm gonna choose not to so I
missed a piece of content which is
something that like as a player I feel
like we're very much trained to like
explore every corner do everything kind
of get on get on money's worth right and
see every cranny it was a weird moment
where I was like I'm choosing not to
engage with a piece probably probably
someone put a lot of work into that
house and there's probably a cool story
in there I missed out on in this game in
particular there's a lievable amount of
depth to this stuff that's off the
critical path Jesus that's interesting
man there's a whole other game to be
played but that's cool finished what do
you think the pollution rate for the
Lost was part 2 as I looked it up 60% I
can 30% across the board on most games I
would I'm gonna guess the Last of Us is
maybe a little lower than five cents a
20%
that's actually I was gonna guess like
even lower than 20 I was like teens who
I was gonna be like probably 20 percent
because it's really long and it can be
very harrowing the completion rate for
the loss was talked to is 55 percent
what's up you're just incredible what
that is
I already it's barely been out for two
weeks fifty-five years I say that is
because the people that are playing it
are playing it and it's it's not like
Red Dead where you are it's an
incredible game people like and you just
kind of fall off and here's the thing
with that game Troy and and this is a
really interesting part of this
conversation that that's really him so
when we say oh if someone feels like the
loss of his plot to was too long and I
had moments where I was like I feel like
this drags I fully understand what you
was saying last week Troy and also very
much respected in the same way I respect
majora's mosque actually is that the
length and the struggle of playing
through it and a feeling like how is it
still going perfectly mimics what the
characters are going through which is
the opposite of ludonarrative dissonance
right so like I feel like that that is a
very effective use of that but a thing
with the last of his part to that I feel
like people might be saying it's too
long is because this is a game that is
so easy to play and that's what I said
from the start I have trouble putting it
down that you're just playing it for
really long chunks of time when you play
it it's true whereas there are other
games that you play for an hour and then
put down I only play Animal Crossing for
20 minutes and then I never play it
again so even though I put 300 hours in
I don't say animal Crossing's too long
it's because if something is
particularly engaging you can feel like
you've spent way too much time playing
it which is on you and not necessarily
on that game and I imagine that's
happening with the last of his part too
if 55 percent of people who've played I
have finished it and it only came out
last Friday I guess a little bit it's
crazy good stuff like you're competing
for anyone like watching this like 30
percent is like the generic standard I
think most of my games come in 35 40 %
and I'm proud of sounds like that's I'm
really curious to see what the
conversion rate was because they had
anticipated that they were probably
gonna have about a 15 to 20 percent
convert
rape from people that played Last of Us
part 1 - 2 Last of Us part 2 and I was
like that's insane I would thought the
conversion rate was like same thing like
70 80 % they're like oh no we think it's
gonna be one the best conversion rates
we've ever had and we're still 85 80 to
85 percent of the people will never have
played the first part I was like that's
that it's so baffling to me bonkers to
me so I'm curious to see if if their
completion rate is is that truly
remarkable if the conversion rate ended
up being the same way you know I mean
the source publicly it's literally you
can be skimming yeah which is super
interesting to look at it and I don't
know dying why it was a game that had a
really high completion rate and I was
always found that one really interesting
because I also finished that game that
makes sense though it was just like I
just [ __ ] love playing through that
game I don't know why like I feel like
maybe that was in credit to its pacing
and that that game is really fast paced
like the way that you run around the
city is so much fun like it was just a
lot of people wanted to finish dying
light for some reason and yeah last was
pot - being 55% was 50 it was fifty
three point six nine exactly this is
like crazy surprising considering the
length and how people are complaining
about it being too long but again the
only pilot that might be that that's
just because it's a game we're playing
very quickly so it feels I also know the
number I'm interested in as well is in
six months because I think I wonder if
and right now because it's very
site-geist II I wonder and not to
perspire obviously as amazing but like I
wonder if that number comes down once it
becomes not the thing you have to have
an opinion on I wonder if that will kind
of people if in a couple of months when
people out of the gate into it what when
they when they come in if that number
kind of comes down and reverse towards
the mean but still it's very super
impressive it's a shame we don't know
the conversion I know the conversion
numbers would be public and I know skin
can use skin can you skin like
PlayStation accounts and like look for
Beatty people who owned both games
on their accounts it's not talking about
me as a consumer as a consumer
I mean it's it's it's actually worth
kind of mentioning like that's actually
a really that's a big public because we
cuz Indies so Sony obviously they have
all the numbers on every games ever
released on PlayStation Rio right all
the users they can they could really
figure out like they can I might have
the conversations with Sony where like
we know your games sell like this this
will do this we know the games the ten
games that came out in your genre at
this time of year last year this is this
is ruffled obviously they don't share
private information but they'll say this
is where we think you're gonna I know
they're very they do a lot of analysis
they're very into it as an indie
obviously I only know about my games I
only know all the data about games we've
made right so in the indie space off and
yes there's a lot of like sharing people
asking questions like I will 100% on the
down low like ask someone who's made
something I'm in the same genre as my
upcoming game well that's but also
there's a lot of skimming there's a lot
of like that's what steam spy was like
that yeah a lot of let's find the public
data and let's try and find patterns
within it and sometimes that's a bit of
a nonsense thing sometimes the data's
really bad that you get back from it but
this there are people who spend a lot of
time trying to figure out like there's
those people who have relatively a
relatively sure sure that they can tell
how well the game's gonna sell on launch
day based on how many wish lists it gets
or also how many games has a game on
Steam sold by looking at how many
reviews it's hard because an outside you
something I can back up like all of our
games basically you can you can you know
the number of like how many people buy a
Biffle game and then review it so
therefore you you could look at our
numbers if you knew that number based
upon review that's that's like there's a
lot of of terms that are lauded and
thrown out there that I think the
general public don't understand like the
difference like oh would this game
shipped 10 million copies and people
like wow it's sold 10 million like no no
no it shipped 10
we don't know how many it's sold is like
well we should know how many it's Souls
like you're not a shareholder you're not
privileged to that information the well
the other the other limits brilliant is
Thomas was allowed and sold two million
units
how much for though yeah Humble Bundle
more than more than one of my games has
like hundreds of thousands of extra
units if on Steam spy due to a single
Humble Bundle sale on the day or
whatever every game that was in the the
black lives matter bundle that was on
each games or something
yeah house again so I think it's sold
like a million copies yeah so literally
every game in that bundle
yeah yeah it's it's hard to you guys
know sorry the other half of this that I
like feel very passionately about but
also don't want every game to do is I
always want games to have more player
agency like that is the thing in writing
that I'm very invested in is like the
idea that we have like nobody don't make
a very specific kind of game they make a
very cinematic game and I absolutely
don't want them to start making the kind
of game that they are good at making but
I also want to see more games where like
cyberpunk which I played last week the
week flaw I don't even know what day it
is anymore
the camera was never taken away from me
once actually it wasn't once but only
one time for about two seconds to look
at a drone and and so let me look
wherever I wanted that whole time and I
feel like that in terms of something
feeling too long is has a huge impact
because you feel like you're in control
of absolutely everything that's
happening and I think why the game's way
you have to like I mean quantum breaks
are really really good one for this you
literally have to put the controller
down and watch a TV show it feels like
it lasts longer because you're watching
things rather than actually constantly
contributing to things and I think that
gives you a different sense of this is
too long this is not too long because
you don't have control I'm very much
advocate for one in games that do give
us more player agency rather than having
set pieces again not to say I want to
get rid of the ones that don't do that I
just want more variety in it and I'm
curious to see as we are there are
several games that I know
that are in development that are trying
to do this which is a instead of having
a cutscene we just fix what half-life 2
did where you can do whatever you want
in a scene but we're not gonna let you
jump all over people like an idiot
you'll be locked into something but you
still have full control over the camera
so you're talking to someone and
braiding their hair at the same time so
it's you're still interacting with
things while something is happening and
I wonder how much of it influenced that
approach to game design will have on the
idea that certain games feel like that
too long do they not feel as long if you
have more player agency or more control
or is it exactly the same like I
genuinely don't know even even last of
us to does does that a bunch of times
where you're it's a walking and talking
and and you're navigating the scene but
I can't draw my gun and I can't like
craft a medkit in the middle of this
conversation was you know yeah you can't
even change the how quickly you're
walking in a very strong way with like I
feel like I may have said it last week
but that's how you one why I be got buff
and how it's like yeah you anyone who is
mad about that you missed it because
it's it's literally in the gameplay it's
known in the cutscenes that leaked
that's a really good example and yeah I
just feel like that we're gonna see more
and more games and again I know of a few
that are trying to do this dying like
two is actually trying to do this where
it's more about player agency or more
about letting you have interaction of
the cutscenes rather than taking the
camera away from you cyberpunk I played
for hours it didn't have a single
cutscene and that felt really odd
especially even compared to The Witcher
3 where basically every conversation you
have is effectively a cutscene and that
you're looking at Geralt you're looking
another person you're looking at Geralt
you looking scary it's it's scary to
give you all that control alone or I
know I love the people are doing it but
it's terrifying like it was an example
of like I was I was driving a car and
there was a police chase or some kind of
chase to the side that I didn't really
look at and the designer that I was
talking to was like that took me about
two years and he might have been too
much whatever it was it was a long time
there are studios right now that are
actively working on can we do a
narrative experience with
doing any kind of cinematic thing that
is not first person when you do first
person that's easy to do right but when
you're when you're telling a
third-person action-adventure story
there's just this natural assumption
that you'll put that within a cinematic
space and they they've explored and
they're trying to now expand upon the
system that they already found to proven
to be first of all effective but also is
incredibly more cost-effective because
you no longer have to do this big
cinematics are expensive and they're
expensive to shoot they're expensive to
put in your pipeline they're just
they're very very expensive so you can
keep everything in game and have it just
kind of be like here's a cinematic
moment but you're still on the stick and
then you kind of keep going sure how
many hours of mocap did you record for
part two I mean we shot me personally
yeah somebody asked me that yesterday I
think I taught I shot a total of six
days if I'm that that's done including
being in the booth and doing vo because
there's a lot of walk and talk stuff
that we did but I I think all in I was I
was only on set for about six days now
they obviously shot I mean my gosh
there's life there's three hours of
cinematics that are in the game you only
do the mocap on the cinematics you do
you do Joel's walk for sir for example
or is that oh yeah so I got on part one
there we did a whole new set so it's
crouches and and stands and walks and
everything else and so even like when
you see Ellie and stuff stand there and
like show her idols and stuff like
she'll scratch the back of her neck
that's 100% Ashlee doing that oh that's
cool yeah it's like she always feels
very cohesive so I wondered if that was
how it was done yeah that's great the
same thing with Abby that's something
that is like look at me now if there's
big vaults and stuff like that they want
to get as much as they can with you but
then at the end of the day we're gonna
look pretty goofy doing that and it's
far better to bring in people there was
one thing that we did in uncharted 4
where Sam is doing this one aren't hang
and I really really wanted to do it and
they needed to get my face for it as
well I found out that it's incredibly
hard to do it one-armed hang so I did
what I could and then they got my stunt
double to come in and did a badass
version of it so Horatio
all right so we have to wrap up but I
did just Dakota me that next week would
be episode 20 which in theory we should
do long as opposed to be live so we'll
figure out that
the rules to be every ten yeah
so the handshake either by the way knows
we can't I guess knows what blow the
whole Kovac thing wouldn't do like a
proper spoiler cause for the lost of his
pot to I told people I don't know if
that suits the show but Mike do you
think that there's even a chance that
you have the game finished by like D
mike d I were you at where you at I can
tell you where you I mean if I'm not I
tell you what we'll do this if I'm not I
will politely sit out and you guys can
do it because I think people want it now
I don't want to be there I don't want
delay it so I'm I wear my I I'm in
Seattle day two so I got ways to go
bye-bye we'll figure it out and I
believe a alia pin comment to update
everyone on that yeah as well so yeah we
should be live next week I'll tweet it
out and all that good stuff we'll see
you then everyone bye
[Music]